we had a dinner party and late into the
night when the alcohol had been taken
the dancers said who are you casting and
I said I don't know it could be a man
could be a woman would just write in the
audition notice you know that has to be
played by a trans person
and I was well aware of what was going
on very quickly became aware that I was
being ostracized from my own company and
then you have the leaders at the top and
I think they come from the same probably
a little bit older generation than me
they had a great time they probably feel
a bit guilty they probably did a few
things they wouldn't want remembered or
they don't want to become a hashtag no
you know and so they're going to keep
quiet look towards their pension look
towards hopefully an Obe and just try
and keep their organization afloat
before they move on so I didn't expect
to be canceled in my own home I didn't I
knew nothing about intellectual property
I know everything now
I was like well I made it it's mine
no no it's more complicated than that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a fantastic guest today is a
Dancer who was forced out of her own
dance company for having as usual the
wrong opinions Rosie K welcome to
trigonometry hello thank you very much
for having me it's really nice to be
here it's really great to have you on
the show uh tell us who are you what has
been your journey through life uh my
name is Rosie k
um I train from the age of three to be a
dancer I never thought that I could do
it as a job
um it just seems something so far away
and spectacular and I was lucky enough
to see some very good dance when I was
young and growing up I saw Nuri F live I
saw the German Coke for Peanut bearish
Live when I was a teenager and
um I got into dance school amazingly I
got into London contemporary dance
school still thought I don't think I can
do this as a career performed toward the
world for five or six years and then
realized that I wanted to be a
choreographer I wanted to make not just
the dance not just the movements but the
stories and I was always very inspired
by quite political female choreographers
people like Martha Graham
um or Mary wigman sort of amazing woman
that made work about the world that they
live in and so I set up my own eponymous
company in 2004 in Birmingham and I've
spent the past sort of 20 years building
up from very small solo duet Trio work
into large scale the biggest theaters
and up until 2021 was touring the world
with my dance Productions yeah
and then what happened and then what
happened
uh I was 10 days away from a big
premiere of Romeo and Juliet which I'd
been spending five years researching
working with gangs gang members schools
in Birmingham Community groups and
different artists
I'd put together a contemporary
birmingham-based version of Romeo and
Juliet and it had got put back and put
back and put back because of covid and I
really wanted to still work and have a
show ready and give people jobs because
it was a nightmare for artists recovery
it just stopped so I managed to get
through auditions and rehearsals we're
10 days away from the premiere and there
was just this very strange vibe in the
company very young dancers some of them
had never performed professionally yet
because they were straight out of
college they hadn't had graduation shows
so I invited them to my house we had a
dinner party and late into the night
when the alcohol had been taken I was
asked what my next show was and I was
well in on the way to Preparing a
production of Romeo and of Orlando which
is a Virginia Woolf novel about there's
an eponymous there's an amazing hero who
turns from a man into a woman it just
happens Virginia wolves writes about it
very Whitley
but also she does 400 years of history
and she changes style all the way
through so it's a really clever funny
book anyway the dancer said who are you
casting and I said I don't know it could
be a man could be a woman would just
write in the audition notice no that has
to be played by a trans person
and I was well aware of what was going
on I was watching it from a kind of
Outsider but from a female perspective
as a woman in the Arts going I can see
what some of the dangerous implications
are to this movement if we redefine what
women are it could pull women's rights
back and it could pull back the
advancements we've made
um so I just pushed back a bit and then
really quickly it turned into
an argument and I was making those
points around women's safety women's
dignity and then also around children
and um how children were being pushed
down and affirmation model and I don't
need to explain all this to you because
you have amazing guests that explain all
this
um it was met with utter hostility
I went back to work I felt I was sort of
wall of woke hate it was a really
vulnerable position when you've got a
Premiere coming up and your company has
turned against you I asked I had sorry
had so you have this argument with these
people who you're trying to give jobs to
yeah and then how how does that become a
wall of hate that you feel so we'll go
back into the studio in the Monday and
with the same people with these same
people okay these same people and I
could just feel the the temperature yes
and I was really scared and I thought
you know the production could fall apart
so and I I and I felt really shocked and
really scared I'd kind of opened myself
up and I'd revealed things about like
the near death of my baby and myself
through childbirth and you know tried to
sort of say listen you know
as a woman who is older than you these
are experiences that only a woman could
go through and here they are you know
please take them to understand how how
much this like how important the body is
we cannot I feel as a dancers and ask
you can't deny that we have bodies this
is important
anyway I felt this wall so I asked um
the chair of the board who was a friend
who I'd worked with who I trusted if she
would help intervene to just calm it
down
I think really the approach should have
been you're all adults it was two in the
morning you were talking about something
contentious you're allowed to have
different opinions that's it get on with
the work instead something happened I
don't know what happened but I very
quickly became aware that I was being
ostracized from my own company
I went through one investigation which I
wholeheartedly cooperated with I was
exonerated what would you be
investigated for I couldn't quite
understand I couldn't kind of I couldn't
get them to define whether there was
something around inappropriateness
but there was something about the fact
that they were so offended and I kept
saying well you do realize that the very
definition of what they're offended
about
transphobia is is the fact that I have
defined women and men as being
biologically real like that's that
that's the issue we have here they're
going to get more and more offended but
the fact is there is that there is
there's a problem here and that's fine
we just need to move on
um so I was investigated
um
I I did make an apology that wasn't
enough for one dancer they walked out
and appealed
and so then it went into a really dark
second investigation and by mistake they
forwarded me a lawyer's email so I could
see that they were spending a lot of
money on outside lawyers to investigate
me again who's they the board the board
I know this is probably a really stupid
question but I neither I or a lot of our
owners May understand this if it's your
own company how are these people in
charge of investigating it absolutely I
should have said that so
um I set it up I was the director of it
it was a limited by share company around
2017 I stood down as director and I
turned it into a charity in order to get
the bigger funding right yeah and we
were we became a regularly funded Arts
Council organization but under English
charity law because it had my name and
it was my work I could not be a director
so also I just had a baby and I'd never
had a salary holiday pay pension so I
was like you know what I'd quite like to
try being an employee for a little bit
it quite quickly I realized I didn't
like it because
[Laughter]
being the boss and it doesn't matter if
it's
coming in it's through you but if you
let go of that power this is what
happens and I and I should have I should
have realized that I thought well hey
let's do this compromise in order to get
that funding in order to get the company
to that big level I'll take that
sacrifice inside because it's going to
get me where I want it to go but that
was a mistake so second investigation
second investigation I see that they're
lying they're spending vast amounts of
money that I had earned for the company
um they're acting in my view and
in legal opinion untoward to the law can
I put it that way
um even like little well not little
things but I asked for this
investigation to be paused because very
close family member had an emergency
operation they refused to pause they
were acting in such a way that I knew
that I would never be able to trust them
again or work with them again and so I
resigned citing constructive dismissal
and discrimination
I was building a case to sue them I
would have sued them but they folded the
company and then despite there being a
really decent amount of money in
reserves when I left it went into
insolvency wow so that puts it into a
completely different legal thing
um I've been fighting over the past year
I've brought out the entire assets of
that former company including my name so
I now own that but again that was
another legal fight that I had to do
behind the scenes isn't it amazing that
all this happened over let's be honest
basically
a heated discussion over a few bottles
of wine
yes it is it it's really shocking and
and there's kind of like a few theories
about like why because on the one hand
you have the activists who are young and
I think have been indoctrinated I don't
think they're very nice they certainly
don't have empathy but I also think
they're probably victims of this and
then you have this kind of capitulation
and cowardice of a board now they're
called Trustees for a reason in that you
should trust them now the interesting
thing I think is actually the artist who
this is all meant to serve is actually
the most vulnerable position because
you're the one making all the problems
you're the one that's still trying to do
your job it was written into the
charitable objects that Rosie K tackles
controversial and taboo subjects shining
a light on things that are unspoken or
unsaid that was my job so of course if
there's something controversial going on
I'm right there in it going what's you
know what's going on tell me you're
young what's what's what's your opinion
well I don't agree with that but this is
what I think and and I'm used to that
back and forth you you should be able to
debate these things I felt and do you
think this is a culture because we talk
a lot about the culture in universities
but we don't tend to talk about it in
the culture and drama schools in dance
schools are they is that very much a
culture within those types of
Institutions well I I hadn't realized
quite so much at the time but yes it is
yes yes and I and I've heard from
insiders that they're quite hostile
environments if you don't agree with
this yeah yeah really because when I
like I went to drama school and it was
tough it was a tough environment and
actually people didn't really care about
your feelings at all so it kind of
surprises me that it's gone completely
the other way
yes and I mean I've got a few theories
about why that happened I'm I'm not sure
so much but I mean there's definitely
that's the pipeline feeding in
um I think things dramatically changed
when it started um I I got a grant to go
to dance school which was just
incredible
um once people started having to pay for
fees
um that that immediately changed the
demographic of who was going to go into
those professions and live with that
level of debt when you have a very very
poor work situation to earn money very
poor
um and so a lot of the Grassroots of
drama of music of dance the Grassroots
in local communities that stopped as
well so the pipeline into the
conservatoires has dried up so the
people that are going there are going to
be actually let's say they're of a
certain class and wealth and privilege
to even be there in the first place so I
think it kind of feeds into that whole
luxury belief system and the problem
then comes because you talk about what
you do and immediately I listen to to
what you said about what your dance
company did and I actually really
enjoyed that so I'm thinking oh that's
what I'm interested in that's what I
love I love theater I want to see
taboo's challenge I want to see
interesting work what does it mean for
the arts and culture and society as a
whole if we can't even have these
conversations or these discussions
particularly in the Arts
gosh well I mean I'm still thinking
about like like like how did this happen
how how did these activists get in and
sort of pollute and poison and change
the entire environment that means that
actually speaking out is such a
dangerous thing to do and that that's so
serious
I remember like um in 2021 I put
together a series of talks with military
people academics and artists and there
was a guy from The Secret Service and I
was asking him like like why did they
pick on the artists you know it's either
political activists that gets sort of
the knock in the night or it's artists
and he said well absolutely you you lot
of the difficult ones you you should be
out there asking questions challenging
Society tend to be very independent
thinkers
um he said we're used to watching this
in Secret Service uh kind of
organizations we see it happening in you
know normally
countries with already authoritarian
regimes and it comes from the top down
we're just not used to seeing it in the
west and we're not used to seeing it
coming what it feels like it's bottom up
but I think it's so long term that that
it's kind of all crunched around us all
at once and do you feel do you feel a
chilling effect is is this what people
are talking about in the world of dance
so they feel that they can't talk about
a particular issue or if they can talk
about it you can only talk about it in a
certain way
I think what's happened is is
it's quite complicated I think you have
the the activists coming in who probably
don't have skills so we've sort of
recently heard that they're coming out
of drama school unable to do Shakespeare
I'd say they're coming out of dance
school
what I would say noodling they're
noodling around there isn't sorry
they're coming out of drama school
unable to do Shakespeare yeah I think
there was an article in the times this
week about actors going to the globe and
unable to speak or learn or get their
minds and mouths around Shakespeare and
like that's the site so so we're
de-skilling that Workforce and through
that skill now it's really important
because people go oh who cares about
Shakespeare whatever but unless you have
that really deep rigor and discipline
and practice like daily practice you
don't have anything to build on then you
really are into rt40 territory so it
dance it's like the rigor of ballet the
rigor of technique with acting it's it's
the voice it's the language it's the the
meaning of those plays you need that
depth to then be able to turn that to
everything else if it's just surface
level then what are we left with we're
left with their identities and they're
coming to the workplace where their
identities are the most important thing
not they are Hearts so you have that
also they can they can make their name
young people without the discipline the
stamina the resilience can make their
names by creating a huge who Heart by
making a mass level complaint getting
their names out there
you then have a system of management or
administrative kind of like control we
have no such like huge controls on
funding that's created an entirely new
class of Arts bureaucrats I'd call them
The Poisoned administrators
often frustrated artists themselves but
very clearly saw that if they want a
salary a position and Power
they that's where they need to go and
then they kind of AstroTurf the whole
thing so they create the programs the
you apply for funding criteria that fits
that program they put the festivals on
so they become the power Brokers within
this world and then you have the leaders
at the top and I think they come from
the same probably a little bit older
generation than me they had a great time
they probably feel a bit guilty they
probably did a few things they wouldn't
want remembered or they don't want to
become a hashtag no
you know and so they're going to keep
quiet look towards their pension look
towards hopefully an Obe and just try
and keep their organization afloat
before they move on and there aren't the
people in leadership's positions
that are justifying their salaries
they're not standing up for the Arts
they're being bullied by the activists
by the Twitter attackers and sometimes
by their own stuff so what you're really
talking about is it's the culture eating
itself because at the very core of this
what people always when I've said I want
to be an acting trainer why do you need
three years it's I always said to there
is a reason why British actors are the
best actors in the world yeah it's
because of the rigorous training that we
receive in this country in Shakespeare
learning how to perform learning to
learning to train your body to train
your voice
if we don't have that we literally have
nothing
well it and it it's really it's just
really weird in the studio when you're
trying to make a work and I've put
together something called the charter of
creation that's asking people if they're
going to work with me to sign to say
that we're free to speak we're free to
disagree that the most important thing
is the art form and in the art form we
should be looking at the depths and
Heights of humanity and we should be
free to do that and also I think you're
only ever going to be really challenging
these ideas if you feel free you can
play you can make mistakes you can argue
and really I I'd much prefer if people
left their identities at the door you
know it used to be sort of leave your
problems at the door now you've got to
leave your performative self at the door
in order to make art and I I just find
it astonishing that that needs to be
said but I just I don't think there's
been a really good argument about what
the purpose of the Arts are for and why
they're so important for Humanity for
culture for civilization for society but
they are they're vitally important and
when they're dead and gone it's going to
be dark very dark
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
Burr turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
we've already not just got out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 as simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American birth which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian word if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
travel packs with your first purchase
this go to athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that's athletic greens.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
it's interesting the point you made I
mean obviously you know you've got the
people at the top as you say who want to
die before they get hashtagged and then
you know they want to be happy I think I
include myself
but it's the bit in the middle which I
think actually you're spot on about
because someone sent me a Mark Twain
quote and I'm gonna butcher but it was
something like when you can't compete on
Merit you start competing on victimhood
an identity has become this
overwhelming wedge that people have
clung to in order to advance careers in
order to get attention in order to be
quote unquote successful and it seems to
me based on what you're saying and what
I've been thinking about that is a
there's a fundamental contradiction
between the focus and identity and
creativity
yes uh I I think
interestingly maybe it's through the
sort of Instagram generation but that
you yourself have become the product and
you are selling you are you are selling
yourself in multiple ways so at first
that was a kind of love Island D type
Vibe and we all kind of went oh the Hell
crass
um but that then flipped into that
identitarian
victimhood so actually like
who you are and what you're coming with
and how you label those those victim
status
sort of markers those are the most
important things so so you're selling
you're selling your victimhood isn't
just victimhood is you're selling that
as a product actually and it sort of
goes against my sense of of having to
work so thoroughly and solidly through
the self that you then become a vehicle
for the art you you can do you can do
anything you might you might be better
at some things than others but I
wouldn't turn down what a role asks of
me or what a choreographer would ask of
me and I would do the same and I'd do
the same in my own work to myself and
then ask that of others that we all hit
sounds a bit silly but we're all here to
serve the purpose of the art the other
thing that comes with this identity
stuff is this full judgment value system
so even at 23 if you have these
protected characteristics that are are
not legal by the way some of these are
made up they can then come in and judge
for example me and all I've got is is
white middle aged women you know it's
like kind of lowest of the low now I
think
there's the straight white man the apex
predator yeah but you don't get code
Karen's you know like that's I'm not
even white particularly but it's Francis
we're looking at yeah
I'm polish Heritage you know and you're
like
I know who I am I've made one
autobiographical work that I made
through lockdown because I could only
work with myself and for a whole year
which was fabulous but that's it I put
it on stage and you can see it so so
they come with this judgment it's
judgment to like oh you know you're the
boss you're the director of the
choreographer and of course you you then
have the weight of Oppression because
you're actually asking these people to
do a job you know for money and they're
judging the work that they're making in
the studio at the same time and so
there's this it's not it's not just your
own internal sense of self-censorship
you're being judged in the studio and I
think that's that's that's lousy and it
totally takes away who the audience is
and I feel like you should make you up
100 into it and let the audience decide
let the public decide let the critics
decide if it's good or bad you just have
to put the most into making it as good
as you can make it yeah and it's like
you know when I was reading about
um without the globe did this version of
Joan of Arc and she's non-binary and and
I just I'm going to swear it's like why
don't you just tell the story of
John
non-binary
but this is it's like the whole thing
feeds itself because you've got this
like powerful kind of bureaucratic
people that are putting the criteria on
I don't think you can blame the artists
for trying to fulfill that criteria yeah
yeah to get the money yes and it is it's
a sort of a self-fulfilling perpetuating
Circle and then I've heard recently that
they're sort of speaking out and saying
oh but we're so worried that these poor
actors are getting attacked by all these
awful people making criticism of this
production it's like well we're not
criticizing well it didn't look very
good but we're criticizing because
you're sort of transiting a female
incredible heroine and some of us object
that that there are so few women of
stature and fame across the centuries
that some of us feel a bit objectable to
the fact that now they're no longer
female or no longer identify as a woman
religious or something that I often ask
people particularly women that we have
on the show to talk about this because I
I do see a bit of attention there
between on the one hand rejecting
identity but on the other hand you
talked about how you were inspired by a
strong female choreographers and so on
is it possible that this is kind of that
same mindset going out of control or do
you see them as different yeah I think
that's really interesting and I remember
like um writing a proposal for for a
piece I wanted to do which was about
looking at my own polish identity and
following that through so I I mean
literally I think till about five
minutes ago I was I probably would have
been woke
to be honest getting canceled we'll do
that to you because I you know I was at
the liberal left I I I mean it's always
these things that you see that that kind
of nugget of Truth around like racism or
sexism and and and you go yeah yeah yeah
oh hang on where is this going hang on
no
but that's that's that's the kind of
cleverness of it of it or the the the
the griftiness of it that that has
pushed it to this place where you're no
longer able to say whoa stop that's
enough that's enough now I think we've
lost Focus so I I think that's what
that's that's why the Arts
what that's why there's so few artists
have spoken out about it I think they've
kind of been pushed down through this
this kind of Sausage Factory with it and
you mentioned uh before we started
actually we were talking about JK
Rowling uh and uh you mentioned it at
one point you tweeted uh she tweeted
something and you replied say agreeing
with her it was a fascinating story
about how people think about these
things
well
um so I decided that I was like okay
identity politics let's go for I'll make
this solo I'll I'll but I'll I'll do it
my way and I'll say all these things
these fun things about myself as well as
the kind of tough things that have
happened to me and I was really it sort
of brought a lot of stuff up about my
own personal history and then JK Rowling
wrote that incredible letter and it said
so much of like what what I've been
feeling and thinking about and working
on on my own in the studio about like
where we're coming from as women and
sometimes it's only when you're older
that you're able to articulate actually
like what it's like being a woman
growing up in the world from from
teenage years or childhood actually what
is it like
well I just remember like being like
a very curious very quiet dancing child
and just fascinated by the world
completely amazed and then there's a
point that happens around the age of 12.
where suddenly you stop being an agent
in the world and suddenly you become the
object it happens when like men just
start commenting constantly on your
appearance when they kind of beep at you
you're wandering around the world in
your school uniform and you're innocent
and you suddenly realize it's actually a
really scary world at which point I also
sort of looked up and looked around and
realized that all these great artists
that I admired they were all men all the
kind of theater directors or the
playwrights most the choreographers they
were all men all the statues around me
they're all men the books I was reading
the heroes that I liked were Tintin or
Cowboy films they're all men and if a
woman came in they had like you know a
fabulous dress on and came in for a
minute and then disappeared they didn't
have their own characters they didn't
seem to be real living well-rounded
human beings the women were sort of
vectors of something else
and so you you know realizing that at 12
kind of profoundly influenced me and I
I don't think it's I it wasn't like oh
wow I realized I was a feminist it was
just like
how do I navigate this and you go
through a difficult time particularly
your teens and particularly over my 20s
difficult being a dancer
entice your body you know a modeled I
didn't like that I much prefer dancing
because you're doing something uh
relationships
um taking risks I mean I've ended up in
ridiculous situations abducted in a taxi
kind of hanging out with Mafia and
Russia like being a hypnold in a bar
like and survived all of these things
and I would rather have dangerous things
happen to me and be free than to never
go out there and live life you know and
then it's only when you know I'm more
settled more secure especially having a
child you look back and go bloody hell
that was like a Warfare out there thank
God I lived you know I'm so glad my
parents didn't know what I was up to and
and and you want to say to younger women
I know you think
this way now
but this is this is what older women
have to tell you you know read some
Jermaine Greer you might not like all of
it but you need to you need to be aware
life is long and women's lives are long
Rosie do you think that's part of the
problem as well with the Arts if you
look at you know those it's been blown
up recently with Romeo and Juliet
zafarelli where the actors complained of
zepharelli's behavior and obviously he's
no longer around to answer those charges
you look at one of the greatest Cinema
cinematic directors of all time Roman
Polanski with the awful awful rape case
and that he's never faced Justice for it
was there was there a culture and an
attitude in the Arts and a predatory
especially for men being predatory
towards women yes yes there was and like
going back to what I was saying earlier
there's a sort of this element of Truth
to some of this stuff yes I think
certain people abuse their positions of
power
um you learn quite quickly other women
older women would support you give you a
nod just watch out for this person there
was certainly people that took advantage
dances full of young beautiful newborn
people you know it does attract a
certain rich or person or personal power
is attracted to that and you have to not
you you used to have to navigate your
way through it I swore to myself I would
not
continue that the kind of buck stops
here and I would say most people in my
generation you know even my teaching
would be quite harsh almost abusified
saying it's like well I don't I don't
ever want to just carry that on I want
to sort of treat people really well
and then here we are I'm the big body
well you know what there is a trolling
me or maybe not a troll or a contrarian
or whatever but a part of me is starting
to go is that maybe why the kids are
like this because we are all so nice aha
is that it's like a vulnerability there
or uh I mean I mean I just mean that you
know you I know what exactly what you're
talking about because in my education
there would have been people who who
would have been I don't know abusive but
but tough right and you know you knew
not to about
I mean when you describe to me the scene
at your dinner party
I cannot imagine myself as that 20 year
old and a person who is employing me
giving me a part in a thing
is invited me for a dinner party at
their house I'm 20 they're 40 or for
whatever they are right
and I am there going you know what I
think you're wrong and in fact I'm going
to come into work to work tomorrow and
give you the stink eye like I can't
imagine doing that I literally
physically cannot imagine and you know
Francis used to run a comedy night where
I I was helping him run it as well and
the sort of like the the Next Generation
coming in the sort of things they would
say about like they would be like I
think the night should be like this yeah
and you're kind of going who the
are you yeah yeah do you know what I
mean I was but I was so like that when I
was young as well I was such a little
Rebel and you know disagreed with this
and disagreed with that but I still knew
just when to shut up sometimes and and
to and to work hard and well if you want
to be on your own get out on your own
and figure it out earn some Stripes you
know don't just yeah so I think we have
been over indulgent and I think there's
been certain messages that the kids have
been right on up till now around like
homosexuality or you know climate change
and I grew up in that generation sort of
arguing my parents at the dinner table
um whereas I now it's gone too far and
and there's probably a lot better people
than me to sit here and say what's
happened to Parenting yeah and to
children and to farming out child care
or farming out
um as Civic local responsibilities so
that we're not we're not involved in
community forums anymore we're not
involved as school Governors you know
that there's there's a level that we as
parents and as adults need to be engaged
in all levels of society not just our
careers well I have a terrifying thought
for you that I've been thinking about is
it possible that when you're arguing
with your parents around the dinner
table
you've become that parent now
I'm asking myself that every day no me
and my husband like have this
conversation like almost every day that
that are we just the grumpy ones I I
certainly think at the beginning there
was that element where you're
questioning it you're going are we just
really out of touch but no I mean when
you look at these big movements that are
pushing through the EDI equalities
diversity inclusion the whole kind of
white fragility White Privilege when
when you look at the core like the the
idea of white privilege comes from this
amazing woman called Peggy MacIntosh and
she she talks about you know the
invisible backpack of of what she
doesn't have to go through because she's
white and it's a brilliant essay it's
fantastic and it also comes with this
fantastic guide as to how not to
alienate people and make people feel
defensive so when like this came up in
some sort of EDI thing and I asked this
sort of the the person running it had
they heard of Peggy McIntosh no as I
said well have you heard of like also
the way that she would bring this in no
it some of these ideas are just being
pushed without a level of nuance and
debate that I think we should be having
the other aspect is with that point
I think in previous generations we'd
have been in more positions of power I
think we're kind of quite a little
sandwich generation that grew up in the
90s had good freedoms worked her way up
expected to get somewhere and get into
positions and when you look at like the
National Theater I think Peter Hall was
like 36 when he got the job of director
it's Unthinkable really that you you
know and so a whole group of us in our
30s and 40s haven't got quite to where
we wanted to other people have stayed on
I'd say probably possibly too long and
we're just getting leapfrogged the
younger generation are just coming in
above us so I think we probably need to
we need to really speak out and take
control a little bit actually
Rosie why is it that the Arts in
particular so vulnerable are so
vulnerable to these type of ideologies
because on the one hand we're talking
about diversity and on the other hand
like I said I've always been passionate
about the theater some of my favorite
actors were you know people in the you
know in the 60s who came from working
class backgrounds Petro too I mean he
actually said he was from the criminal
classes but there were Albert Finney
yeah exactly Michael Kane I'm gonna get
cancer
you know Michael Kane
Richard Burton you know all these you
know Powerhouse British actors you know
from working class backgrounds and you
look at the actors now predominantly I
mean there's very good people like
Damian Lewis went to eat and a lot of
them did so on the one hand the Arts has
become ever more The Preserve of the
wealthy and the upper classes yet at the
same time
it's about diversity and you're like
right so I think you need to sort of
trace a little bit like what's happened
particularly so the funding system in
this country is very strong for the Arts
but it's also always since John and
O'Kane set it up it's always had a
political Edge to it yeah always
if you go back to the 80s and that
tourism the Arts were being very lowly
funded and they had a kind of do you
remember instrumentalism so the Arts are
being used to solve like you know social
woes quite low level but it meant that
artists were quite free they could kind
of like do what they like you also could
claim dull so you could be an artist and
you could get like you know at least
enough to cover your rent and eat so it
was a more genuinely equal sort of
starting point and you were left alone
and I think that's probably around the
point that the Arts became Lefty as they
saw it as a movement against Thatcher
um out of that grew some really
interesting rebellious movements such as
the ybas and The Sensation uh exhibition
sorry to interrupt I know what the yba
should explain to people who's this
artist so you the Damien Hurst
um Tracy and means they kind of really
rebellious art stuff you had the kind of
Mark Ravenhill shopping and
they're really amazing movement that was
going on in British theater you you had
these things that had like a punk Edge
it was rebellious it also did have quite
a capitalistic Edge they wanted to make
money and that was really kind of quite
a clever move then you've got Blair
coming in and the whole different thing
about Blair and the Arts was it's being
used for regeneration so the Arts had
managed to make the business case so
that like okay we go and build a massive
Art Center in gateshead that will then
Revitalize the area
um that'll bring in and they and they
literally crunched the numbers to say
that we can use Arts to to change cities
there was loads of money it was a great
time there was all these performing arts
schools you get like big fees for
workshops you've got the Olympics you've
got these big big big stuff going on
yeah brilliant I'll do this I'll do that
I'm making massive works but slowly
slowly I also realized that that
criteria started to get stronger and
stronger and the artists had less and
less say you were serving quite a big
bureaucratic art business because it was
social engineering really to some extent
right so yeah so I think now that
instrumentalism has kind of Gone full
circle so we're captured by the business
stuff we have to justify every single
penny I would if when I was a regularly
funded organization I needed to employ
someone to just do the data to just
collect the data tiny one person sort of
dance company but we had to produce
mountains of data to justify the money
that I get
um and then you've got the kind of it's
a ripe it's it's just a ripe
house for mold that's what it is and
this stuff has come through and it's wet
mold and it's dry mold and it's just
covered the house because it's rotten
inside and out and we sidetracked you
because you were talking about JK
Rowling that was about three years ago
but tell us more about that story
because it was fascinating so so I think
I think I think it was her letter and I
liked it not on my company account
Twitter account but on my personal one I
liked it and retweeted it put my phone
down went put kettle on came back put
picked up my phone already there was
like you know I don't know what it's
called this massive kind of trail of
messages of people from the Arts World
saying is this the is Rosie k a Turf is
Rosie K transphobic
um is this the official policy of Rose
kedon's company I was absolutely shocked
I was overwhelmed because I was kind of
like that's a brilliant letter no one's
going to argue with that
we were all so naive once
someone to stand up and take a sound and
then everyone again obviously not right
wing someone is obviously
all they have to do is just stand up and
beautifully articulate the point and
everyone will get it yeah and I say oh
my God and my husband's like just delete
it just delete it
just just deleted it and then I felt I
felt a bit dirty I felt a bit bad and I
thought also I'm making work about
exactly this that's going to go on big
stages
okay all right
let's do it but let's do it through the
art let's do it through the art
so I got the solo out there it was
called adult female dancer I wanted to
be called adult human female and I was
convinced by my management just to turn
it down a little bit again it's very
offensive you are right huge difference
yeah yeah so I did this solo show back
in 21 big venues really big like
Edinburgh Festival theater you know
Birmingham rep and I got these amazing
reviews Observer the guardian and in
this solo adult adult female dancer
there is a point where I say being a
woman is not in my head being a woman is
on my head I thought someone would pick
it up and out me no I just got like four
or five star reviews so I was like I'm
out fine let's just keep going this is
like the this is the little line it's
dangerous but I'll play it so I didn't
expect to be canceled in my own home I
didn't didn't expect that one but then I
also a bit like saying about the house
had gone moldy my board were not there
for the Arts either I don't know why
they're there I think there's a much
bigger important question about
governance in the Arts and I'd like to
do some work on that with lawyers to
look at how we can protect I mean I I
knew nothing about intellectual property
I know everything now
it's mine
no no it's more complicated than that
yeah
um so I I think I think we've got a kind
of like upskill ourselves a little bit
as as artists as a movement and I want
to be part of that goal actually maybe
we need a little bit of governance a
little bit of legal advice
um we need to start going out and making
everybody's lives as difficult as
they've made ours
you made a point about how we we all got
into bed with the corporates and I
remember like because I was very Lefty
when I was younger as we all were right
and I think that stage is very important
if I'm being honest I think you should
be at that age
but yeah I remember always feeling
uncomfortable whenever I saw like the
National Theater sponsored by Deloitte
or whatever else and I can never
articulate why but if you're receiving
your money from corporates then how can
you be truly rebellious as an artist
because because Art became a brand I
mean I made this show called MK Ultra
that was looking at conspiracy theory
and I was sort of stunned I was going
you know to all the big theaters and
dance events and I was kind of like kind
of like doing the same thing over and
over again they've got like a brand a
look a Vibe a feel the audience is the
same and then I was looking at pop
videos and like some of it's completely
Bonkers and I was like well that's going
quite avant-garde Why Have Art stopped
being avant-garde and yet mainstream pop
mainstream media we were talking like 10
years ago now is is more experimental
and I thought it was something really
failing already going on there yeah oh
it's a brand you're selling a product
they don't want you to do a different
work every time they want the same work
recycled so that they know what they're
selling
I think theaters are in a difficult
State I mean they're a really bad State
at the moment with the cost of living
crisis and heating
um and they're some of some of them not
all some brilliant Chief execs and
directors out there and program most
Really Brave really get it really see
the future oh and presario's but some
people are just scared and are gonna
just not rock the boat they're the
they're the captain of the of the bounty
you know they don't want a mutiny on
their hands so because we've talked
about a lot about what is wrong with the
Arts
how do we save the Arts because the Arts
need saving because it is truly
transformational I used to teach drama
and you know rough secondary schools up
and down the country I literally saw
kids who couldn't access any type of
education the moment you put them on a
stage they flew and you they developed
it wasn't just about performing it
wasn't just about the fact that they
loved drama and then they loved
expressing themselves it gave them a
dignity because they thought I can do
this
so how do we save the Arts and
okay for first or just a little caveat
is I think that learning departments
within organizations need to have a good
look at
um because that's a lot where this kind
of whether it be critical race Theory or
queer theory is coming through because
the art sits still sometimes over there
but it's the learning and participatory
departments that have just been allowed
to kind of
not learn their trade properly not go
out there with like a really pure clear
message about the Arts they're there for
other reasons to push through ideology
what do I think we need to do in the
Arts I think we need to speak
we need to do
um we need to be it we need to be it
and and and make like just keep making
stuff it I do speak I do want to speak
out but that only takes it so far I've
got to keep practicing my art form and
and get it out there and it's the only
way to also stay real still stay sane
stay embedded you know grounded in that
discipline in that practice and yeah I
want to do I want to do some work that
might be seen as political this year but
I also want to go back to maybe some
pure dance and have that freedom to do
that so I think we need to do we need to
speak and we need to be we need to live
it you know we need to walk the walk
that's absolutely true you know uh this
is I I've stopped doing stand-ups since
the pandemic but we're working on some
interesting things comedically and
whatever and I think that's
you uh you know when you were talking
before about we have to stand up and
talk uh to the you know and advocate for
our generation and you know the point
you're making yeah I was just thinking I
think the solution to this really is to
prove that what we are doing
and the content that whatever that
content is whether it's dance or comedy
or online stuff or whatever is more
popular I that's what you have to do you
have to get past the Gatekeepers that's
really the problem in that it's The
Gatekeepers yes exactly because you've
got people making decisions who are not
making them purely on the basis of what
the public want absolutely they're
making them on basis based on ideology
and we saw this with comedy where you
get people being promoted because they
are trans or because they are this or
because they're there
um and uh that is actually if you can
structurally find a way to get past that
very then easy to prove that that isn't
what the people want because the shows
that do that on TV comedy-wise they're
all canceled now yeah because no one
watches them yeah right yeah so if you
if you create stuff that people do watch
I think that's the answer but you know
what I think it's even more existential
in the Arts I think there is an attack
on live arts and live performance
uh not not necessarily a direct you
but it's audiences aren't returning
those big buildings
I I think you know and if you're putting
on work
that is ideologically seeped I mean I
honestly think audiences hate it but I
also don't think they're necessarily
striving to run out and see great new
challenging avant-garde work either and
so that worries me and and and I do
agree that you know it should be
meritocratic it may be that we have to
kind of
except that those institutions are too
far gone and set up our own ways to do
it whether that be institutions or in
new ways holding on to our values
um but but I but I yeah I worry just
that we we're now moving to a non-live
world and yet I also you know I believe
sitting in that Auditorium when it goes
dark and something live is about to
happen in front of me you know it's the
best most incredible experience in the
world I love it and I think there's
nothing and I love being in the audience
and I love performing there's nothing
else like it to communicate deep
Humanity the Greeks great you know
there's a reason why we need to be and
see and think about difficult subject
matters portrayed by people in real time
it does something to us it's so
important I remember my dad bless him
who's been they had a tough life he's
been through his struggles and it was in
the early noughties I took him to see
Death of a Salesman the Arthur Miller
play yeah and it was I can't remember
the name of the guy played Woody Lowman
he but he Brian Dennehy
and I remember watching it and I was
thinking this is brilliant and I looked
over at my dad who's never really gone
to the theater a lot he doesn't really
come from that world he comes from a
working class background and because I
was worried I was is Dad enjoying it
yeah he was literally on his head of his
seat like this
and it was because it's just such a
powerful I mean Miller's my favorite
playwright yeah and in particular when
you look at things like The Crucible
which is more relevant than ever yeah
and it's so important it's because it's
Primal it's Primal it's about all of us
being together around a metaphorical
campfire telling a story and we need
that and we can't forget it I mean I I
study the crystal at school and I I
never thought I'd be living through you
know yeah an equivalent of the witch
hunts it's just unbelievable and I think
that's you know something that really
needs to be talked about more like the
bullying The Bullying that this is just
allowed the bullies to get into
positions of power and to leverage it
and and it's hard to stand up to bullies
I get it I get why people are scared but
the only way to stop bully is to say
that that's it that's enough and Rosie
one of the things I want to ask you is
why you decided to do that and I know
that it ties into some of the work
you've made actually so talk to us about
that
um so
um I'm just about to bring five soldiers
back and going on tour from April
so five soldiers um and the subtitle to
is the body is the front line
um I was struck by how the body the
physical body the human body is still
essential to Warfare in the 21st century
No matter how the technological changes
have changed Warfare it is the human
body and it's the human body that's
trained to fight
um so quite a long time ago I was doing
a show in London and I suffered a really
bad injury and I was told I'd never
dance again it would take me about a
year to recover and following the
operation of my leg I think the
anesthetic did something quite profound
to my brain
um I dreamed I was lying on a desert
Battlefield and my leg had been blown
off and I could see my leg over there
and my first thought you know sort of
bombs going off and flames and things
um I first thought was oh
but then my second thought was quite
weird my second thought was like well is
my body my soul like where does my soul
reside like I've trained since I was
three years I said to like be a dancer
but like you could chop my arms and legs
off and I'd still want to dance I would
and so I went downstairs and it was the
Iraq War at the time I put the Telly on
and I saw the face of young men killed
in Iraq and and I just thought I wonder
I wonder if how'd they train I wonder
how you train not just to risk injury
like I do in dance but to risk your life
and maybe it's not like the movies maybe
they're not brainwashed maybe they
really really love their jobs and that
allows them to take such risks that
they're willing to risk their lives and
what what is that process
and I thought well there's all poets War
artists
um there's war photographers but the
medium of their job is their bodies
maybe I as a choreographer could go in
I'd never seen a work of dance that
captured like the realness of it
um so it took me years it took me ages
but I got an attachment to an infantry
battalion and I spent time with them
not realizing a bit of an idiot 10
females in the Army oh it'll be 10
female no it's an all-male infantry
battalion it's all male so I end up on
Dartmouth straight away three days and
nights and a big exercise and I started
off absolutely terrified literally
hiding behind people but I'd like for
burger and helmet body armor
and then I got it I just started
watching and realizing oh I can see
what's going on here like that needs a
formation now I started to understand
this sort of physical tactics off it got
quite into it so over several weeks I
went from being a terrified pacifist I
thought bystander to had my own rifle I
was invited to join a battle against a
rival Battalion and I was leaping out of
Windows chucking grenades and you know
you do like you you really rehearse war
and they try and make it as realistic as
possible so there's like smoke and
sounds and like they hate each other
these different battalions you know it's
really full-on
and um I got it I got that experience I
was like okay I just jumped out of a
week don't never mind my my my poor left
leg I I just did it I did that thing I
was like yes sir boom Oh my God I'm
flying out of a window
um I then spent time at Hadley Court
um which is the rehabilitation center
and
by then the guys I was worth training
with they'd gone out to Afghanistan and
it was like one of those Worst Years
really bad years and the Taliban changed
tactics from firefighter
um improvised explosive devices IEDs
so the guys that I was training with
they were now coming back with these
complex traumas and getting their legs
blown off basically we're going to find
a point on it
and then some of the people I actually
knew people that had become friends were
injured so I went to Sally Oak
very near where I live in Birmingham and
I visited a friend who had lost both
legs in Afghanistan as well as multiple
other injuries
um but I went into silly Oak and it was
like Ward after Ward after ward of young
people with now disabling injuries and
yet you know there's still that Army
banter going on in that Vibe and the
government were not releasing the injury
figures they're putting a delay on it
but they were we were getting the
casualty figures so there's like
remember Wooten Bassett so there's this
outpouring of grief for the dead but
there's there's going to be like
hundreds of people that are going to be
living lives
for decades that the British public are
not going to be aware of
this before help for Heroes and all
these kind of Charities they were
starting up around the same time
anyway long story short I made a show
about it it was a one-hour show and it
did okay but when I brought it back in
2015 it just went in the Arts World
massive not not amazing but massively
like five star awards globally touring I
was doing it right up until covert
struck I was turning the US with this
show and it's like a one hour you sit
there you think oh God dance and
Military how crap is this gonna be but
we've had like serving soldiers a guy
that just come back from Afghanistan
he's sort of my God that show he said
it's like doing a six-month tour in one
hour and then he came back the next
night with his wife and teenage kids and
I said I want to show them because I
can't explain how intense it is but this
show does
so we're bringing it back
um I'd love to see that I think it's
good to have a show that's about
fighting because I need to remember that
discipline yeah I think it's relevant
the Afghanistan evacuation last year
brought everything back for anyone if
whether they're still serving or they're
a veteran it was a shock
all that sacrifice that people had made
for for beliefs and values
they believed in did you believe in all
of it they believed in the values of you
know helping particularly women in
Afghanistan you know what's going on
there and then we've got Ukraine and
this idea you know the left the lefties
when I did five soldiers like oh you're
a bit right wing look at the military
and I was like but it's happening it's
really happening we have a professional
military that are at War I think Ukraine
has made people think ah you know that's
on Europe that's all now
land and I think people are looking at
well how do you defend your borders in a
different way
so yeah I think fire soldiers is still
sadly very relevant
and it's it sounds like brilliant art
because it can express the things that
sometimes even a person who's been
through that experience can't express
for themselves so I really look forward
to seeing thank you and it's about this
contradictions and that's what I love
about dance is you know one second you
read one thing and the next minute you
read another and whether that's beer
around the body or emotions or
like the role of soldiering it's lovely
and I don't try and have a political
message with it I try and be as
authentic to those stories and
experiences that I had
fantastic well I look forward to seeing
I'll make sure to do that it sounds
great uh Rosie okay before we let you go
we always ask our final question but uh
before we ask that and of course
questions for our locals only supporters
uh tell everybody where to find you
uh so I have a website called uh
k-2co.com I'm on Twitter Rosie K2 Co I'm
on Instagram and I'm on Facebook and
yeah just uh find me and reach out and
go and see five soldiers
um so what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
I think we're not talking about
Joy enough Joy pleasure fun
I think talking about ideas about real
Joy like joy that lights the soul that
lifts us up that elevates us
Beauty like like not not a superficial
level of beauty but but a real like
gorgeousness of the world these are
deeply unfashionable things right now
and I think that does relate to this
this melee that we're in like being able
to really have fun if you can't let go
and you're worried about you know
censorship or fear or whatever you can't
have fun you can't because it takes away
all spontaneity
so I'm really interested in like how do
we elicit like feelings of Joy how do
artists help that I think it relates to
your world like joy and humor and beauty
and that's we're not talking about these
things but then that's why I'm in
dancing not not not not in politics I
suppose it's like because these are
things that are felt these are things
that are lived these are things that are
in our bodies and we can't just keep
like you know what is it this this ape
in a meat meat sack you know we can't
keep this discarded and kind of like
separation in the mind of the body we
need to get into our bodies we need to
have fun and we need to have pleasure
that be eating or dancing or all those
other experiences of of
finding like fulfillment in ourselves
and and that's up to us you know we have
to do that I completely agree and
sometimes fun can be naughty as well
which is why I think the fun police come
along because they're like No this must
be fun in set parameters and you're like
that's not fun exactly you just killed
it yeah perfect it's been such a
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the show and for everybody watching we
put up
interviews on Wednesday and Sunday 7 P.M
UK times and Roars always go out at 7
p.m UK time as well and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys we'll see on
locals for the bonus questions that
you've already submitted for us take
care
what are the hopes for art as intended
to create Beauty to entertain and to
console to transport and transcend
[Music]